In Mesopotamia. This is happening. The destruction of ancient treasures,
even the leveling of entire cities by the self named Dolan Islamia.
I think the reason this hurts us so much as something to do with language,
we have much older artifacts we even know of older cities,
but the people of Mesopotamia were the first to speak to us on their own terms
in their own words, whose words for starters,
simmer 5,500 years ago, the spoken wrote in [inaudible],
Sumerian and isolate unrelated to surrounding languages.
Even when the Acadians came in and took over 1200 years later,
they kept Sumerian civilization going, Samir and Ising,
their own words and culture as one linguist puts it on a massive scale.
This amazingly early cultural transmission shaped ideas in the Middle East,
in Europe at a time when most ancient languages have to be hypothesized.
We know what the Mesopotamians had to say here.
This is a city they called it Eddie do.
This is how much barley every child and every adult should get 20 points for the
kids, 30 to 40 for the grownups.
This is a story they wrote about a giant flood.
The first documented Semitic language wasn't written in Phoenician or the Hebrew
alphabet. It was in cuneiform human.
The oldest into European texts were written in cuneiform. Now,
I think country to what's gone around on the news.
Cuneiform doesn't make Mesopotamia. Everyone's cradle of civilization.
It's hard to see what kind of impact Sumeria could've had on China.
And certainly the got all in the old mag in the Americas. We're a world away,
but it was this act of writing early and extending its influence to later ages
that causes us to connect with cuneiform civilizations,
to hold them in such high regard and to stand horrified at people who confronted
with that same influence feel. Not respect but hate.
Mm.